they wrote in saying can you list some
of your favorite fiction authors I will
do this there's so many this this is
almost like saying what's your favorite
book and how could I possibly ever
answer that some of my favorite authors
in the sci-fi side arthur c clarke whose
picture you were seeing here author of
the 2001 uh not even trilogy it's a
quadrilogy for books in that series
author of the rama series author of so
many other great great books definitely
when my favorite sci-fi authors Neal
Stephenson who wrote the book Snow Crash
and more recently wrote uh seven Eve's
and another one whose name I'm
forgetting I've read most of neal
stephenson stuff absolutely fantastic
Isaac Asimov Robert Heinlein love love
love these authors and so many others in
the sci-fi world I really really like
both Raymond Chandler and eric ambler
both of whom wrote in the earlier part
of the 20th century although i believe
Raymond Chandler slightly later uh some
of the great great sort of crime
detective intrigue stories love them and
the sort of descendants from them
include both John la'kara and Robert
Ludlum Robert Ludlum of course very very
well known for the bourne trilogy love
those getting into a sort of different
thriller genre uh there I'm just
speaking off without my head they're
just so many authors that I absolutely
love uh I really liked Henning mangles
work the the late uh swedish crime
detective fiction author whose character
Kurt Wallander sort of very interesting
and unusual police officer detective
investigator and I know I'm just missing
so many here it's just I I it's crazy
how many I missing but those are some
authors I like yeah I've been late
lately into kind of adventure historic
novels probably more biographies almost
almost right now I'm reading Quran core
ops his accounts of scaling Everest in
many of the peaks of the world and how
one this one point he actually says in
the book he's like I wish to die right
now in this moment I wish it were all
over because I've lived
most productive and fulfilling life ever
but somehow in that moment he like turns
from that strict straight to I'm going
to survive though because because
there's more to live so but yeah I I
would say I'm big into those type of
book a bberry lot of John Muir and his
accounts of the Sierra and kind of
traversing all these spaces that I've
traveled myself and so your lesson to
fiction it sounds like yeah I'm more
nonfiction more into biography and
realities I guess some other authors
that I I like I mean Agatha Christie is
absolutely fantastic uh I've read quite
a bit of Dostoevsky and it's just such a
different experience it's so difficult
to even say here here are my favorite
authors and i know i'm forgetting so so
many uh Alan first fu rst is a guy who
writes really good World War two ERA
historical fiction so it's taking place
in the in the atmosphere of World War
two but they are fictional stories about
individual characters that he he invents
uh it's a really long list what I
recommend you do is check out david
pakman.com slash recommendations because
a lot of my book recommendations there
are by some of my favorite uh Christian
I'm sorry not Christian authors I am NOT
into christian fiction fiction authors
Christian and fiction are very similar
could we call that a Freudian slip uh I
I think we can I think so maybe you're
into acidic novels too who knows let's
move on oh that reminds me there is such
a great novel by Michael Michael I
believe that last name is pronounced
chabe on the yiddish policemen's union
and it is an awesome Alaska detective
novel it is absolutely fantastic i
recommended it's on my recommendations
page not exactly Hasidic fiction but I
lose the word Yiddish is in there